you want to be the person that if you
could pick your best friend
you know that you would have the same
qualities that's one of the most
important exercises that you can ever do
in your life
some other common uh keystone habits are
rise and shine it's entspresso time
hey it's evan carmichael and i am not a
morning person
but when you start your day with a
routine that inspires you
like watching one of these videos it
will change your life
so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee
know that i believe in you and get ready
for a shot of espresso from warren
buffett
i wake up every morning
what other habits did you cultivate in
your 20s and your 30s that you now see
as being foundational to your success as
a business person
well i i knew a lot
about what i do uh when i was 20. i mean
i i i really read a lot and
i aspired to learn everything that i
could about the subject so
intellectually i knew a lot
i did not know a lot about human
behavior i mean that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's
it's very important to understand people
and uh i say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
or you could be given 10 of the future
earnings
of one person that you know among
everybody you know
now are you going to pick the person
that's the smartest i'm going to pick
the person that can
dance the best or that can run the
fastest or anything like that that's the
right height
no anything no no they're you're gonna
you're gonna
pick the person that has the right
habits that that
is cheerful generous gives other people
credit for what they do
you know and when you look at all of the
qualities that you admire in other
people
which would cause you to pick that
person say to yourself which of those
qualities
can't i have myself because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper
who is the person that you admire the
most or like the best
why do i like them and just write down
and then
say which of these can i do myself and
the truth is you can do them
and then you also if you really want to
carry it to the next extreme you pick
the person you dislike the most
and why do you dislike that person you
know and you know
they always they're never fair about
things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities
and say if you dislike that some other
person why in the world would you want
to have those yourself
so you get rid of those and it's a
pretty simple thing to do
but you want to be the person that if
you could pick
your best friend you know that you would
have the same qualities
if you want to be the best version of
yourself you have to figure out your who
your who is your single most important
value and once you
find it it gives you the road map for
the rest of your life
if you're ever unhappy if you ever feel
like you're not living up to your
potential
if you ever feel like there's something
more inside you and you want to do it
you want to hit it you want to achieve
it you want to be
all you can be you have to figure out
your who
in my book built to serve i talk about
this i give you a simple process to
follow of how to figure out your who but
i want to break it down for you
in this video because if you're ever
not happy or if you ever feel like
you're living below your potential it's
because
you on a daily consistent basis are not
living
your who and your credo and the credo is
the three things that make up your hoop
so let me break it down for me as an
example
and then i'm going to guide you the
process to do it for you too so my who
is belief
[Music]
i want to spread more belief in the
world i think it's the world's number
one problem
and i need to believe in myself more as
well i believed in myself to get to
everything that i've done
but i don't believe in myself enough to
do the next step
and that's a constant journey a constant
climb a constant battle
that's that's where growth comes from on
the next level of belief for me
and whatever your who is for you you
might have
people in your life telling you that
you're you're so great at x
people tell me but you're mr believed
how do you not believe in yourself well
i do for everything that i've done but
not enough yet for where i need to go
your greatest growth is on the other
side of more of whatever you're who
is one of the things that
i i missed in my first book your one
word
where i talk about this is i didn't
spend enough time on the credo and the
credo is your definition of your who
so if you think about your who is your
single most important core value
i want you to break that down into three
steps so for me what does believe me
turn it from believe to hashtag believe
that's what makes it custom
for evan carmichael for me believe means
believing in what you're doing that's
having the passion having the passion
for the work
that you're doing i believe in what i'm
doing it's believing in yourself
self-confidence and then believing that
it's going to work out
that that if you keep putting in the
work that eventually it will work out
because sometimes it's hard sometimes
you think this is gonna go anywhere i
don't know what's happening why am i
putting so much time in here
believing that it will work out so
believing in the work passion
believing in yourself self-confidence
and believing that it will work out and
having the conviction to follow through
believe breaks down to those three
things for me
right passion self-confidence and
conviction
what you need to do now is figure out
what is your single most important core
value
your who and what are the three things
that make it up so in build to serve
there's a few exercises that i go
through that i want to run through
quickly here in in this video to figure
out
who you are and this is your best self
this is in alignment with your best self
right i'm my best self
when i'm living believe when i believe
in myself when i believe in the work i'm
doing when i believe that it's going to
work out that's my best self that's who
i really want to be
and every day is a is a constant battle
to try to be that person
but that's who i want to be so for you
i want you to make a list of all the
things that make you come alive
i want you to think about who your who
your favorite teacher was growing up
what your favorite books are your
favorite songs your favorite movies
and then for each one write down three
words
so who was your favorite teacher and why
three words
not not paragraphs right just three
words
why that teacher you've had so many
teachers in your life growing up why
this one teacher
why did one teacher stand out it wasn't
because she she taught you grade 10 math
right what was it she made you a better
human
the teacher made you a better person why
right write down those three characters
the three values that that person had
same thing for your favorite movies your
favorite songs what you what you loved
about your parents
and how they raised you you may not like
your parents you may have had terrible
parents but there's something that you
can respect and appreciate about them
and so all the things that have made you
come alive right give a book
favorite movie favorite song what you
love about your parents favorite teacher
favorite friends growing up who are the
people around you that make you come
alive and then why
three words for each and then what i
want you to do is think about
as you write down these words what are
the what are the common elements between
them what word pops up over and over and
over and over and over again
what's the one word that keeps showing
up that's your who that's your one word
that's your most important core value
and then the other ones around it make
up
your who for you those will be your
credo the credo are the three things
underneath your most important core
value so you got your who
you got your who at the top your most
boring core value up here and then the
three things underneath
your credo and often inside that is
something that means something to you
that doesn't
immediately resonate with other people
so if i talk about belief
as my most important core value if you
think what is a dictionary definition of
belief or
what would most people say belief is
most people believe that it's
self-confidence right
believe in yourself but then adding the
other two layers of believing in the
work having passion
and believing that it will work out
having conviction makes sense when i
explain it but it wouldn't be the
default thing people turn to that's what
makes believe special for me
that's what you need to do for you as
well so when you look at your list of
all the keywords that you've written
down
from all the people that you've loved
and all the things that have made you
come alive
now you can make your who at the top
and then the creator that makes it up
and if you're having a hard time you're
struggling to figure out well
i don't know which which word fits on
top and which one
is in the credo underneath what i want
you to think about is
is one more important than the other is
one the parent
and the other are the children that's
what we're really looking for is one the
parent and the other are the children
my who is believe and then passion
confidence conviction
is underneath those are the kids that's
what makes up the parent
so in your list of words is one the
parent
and the others are the kids and if
they're not if you find that you've got
three kids
and they're all equal the three would
you come up with they're all equal you
can't pick one over the other as one
more important than the other
then you might have to think of well
what's the parent for these three words
if you got three things that are all
equal
great keep them all equal there's
something higher up there's something
more meta
above it that's what you got to figure
out is your who and
some people get it right away some
people like yeah this is it and they got
it
and some people take a long time to get
it they have to sit with it they got to
reflect they got to come back to it the
next day the next day the next day and
look at it
and if you do that you will get the
clarity if you come back every day and
look at that list again
something will eventually pop off the
page i promise i've seen it happen so
many times with people
it can be frustrating for some people to
take so long to get but
it's one of the most important exercises
that you can ever do in your life
this is why so many people are lost
confused and unhappy because they don't
know
who they are they don't know what
they're who is they're constantly living
somebody else's version
you're living somebody else's version of
your life you're doing the things that
your parents want you to do and your
friends want you to do what society
wants you to do
and if you feel like you're being pulled
in a million different directions by
other people's expectations
it's because you don't have clarity over
who you are
this exercise gives you that clarity and
it will be with you for your entire life
i'm going to be
180 years old still believing in people
and you will too for whatever your one
word is whatever your who
is my wife nina her who is care she's
her best
when she's caring for other people she's
her best when she's spreading care she
cares for herself
she cares for others she's going to be
190 years old
and she's still going to be caring about
people that's her best self
so if you want to be your best self you
want to
live the life that you're capable of
living you want to be proud of yourself
daily you want to be able to know why
you feel
low and down and lack of energy when it
comes up
and you want to have the roadmap to get
to a happier place where you're serving
when you're feeling great where you're
inspired where you're motivated
where you're helping other people out
and when you're actually living up to
your potential
you have to figure out what your who is
you can go through the entire process or
and build the serve or you can just
rewind this video and watch it a few
times and do the exercises
because it is it is i think one of the
single most important lessons
that if you find the answer to will
serve you for your entire
life now i've got a special bonus script
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week
when you watch a video and you just get
inspired the statistics say you have a
35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated through a video
and then you actually create a plan of
action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through from 35
to 90 plus because you created a plan of
action
and when you commit to somebody else
commit publicly say i'm going to do this
it jumps to the mid 90s that's what i
want for you because believe nation
we take action we follow through we
don't just get motivated
we actually do something about it so we
can make the positive shift in the world
that you want to make and so question of
the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
let me know put it down in the comments
below so i can celebrate with youtube
also if you want to have more self
belief and self confidence check out my
254 series where every day for the next
254 days i will send you an unlisted
video
to your inbox to help you shift your
confidence forward
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to change a habit
you want to change a negative habit you
want to build that new belief
it takes up to 254 days so for free
for the next 254 days i will send you an
unlisted video
to be with you every step of the way to
shift that
habit forward to get in for free check
out the link in the description below
if i ever write a book it's going to be
called why smart people do dumb things
yeah my partner says that it should be
autobiographical if you ask me to write
a story on what is
potomac electric power worth or
something like that i can write the
story and that's what i'm doing every
day i'm assigning myself a story and
then i go out
is there such thing as i guess central
habits that can help to shift
and transform other aspects of your life
because that's
something that i've noticed a little bit
where if i
start eating better or if i start going
to the gym every day it's almost like a
domino or ripple effect where these
other habits start to pick up
naturally because i'm starting to feel
better so like i've been going to the
gym five days a week
so now when i come home i don't feel
like binging out on junk food i feel
like eating better food
or if i wake up early uh is that
something you've noticed in your
research
yeah sure so there are two ways to
answer this question so the first way is
what you're describing is often
sometimes called a keystone habit
and the idea is you do one thing and it
like ripples into other areas of your
life
and so for me it's exercise like if i go
to the gym then i get the benefits of
exercise
but i also tend to eat better i like for
some reason i just don't want to waste
it
i also focus more so i have sort of that
like post workout high
after after i work out and then i sleep
better
because i'm tired from the workout which
means i wake up the next morning and i
have better energy
and at no point was i trying to build
better sleep habits or energy habits or
focus habits or nutrition habits but all
that kind of just came as a side effect
of doing this one thing of going to the
gym some other common
uh keystone habits are budgeting
sometimes people say when they pay off
debt
you'll then they'll like start to get in
shape or they um you know build
they're more social and have better
relationships or like there's all kinds
of things that kind of come out of that
um going for a daily walk is a really
big one it's very common one among
creators in particular
there's a book called daily rituals by
mason curie
and he basically just writes down like
what i don't know it's 100 or 150 famous
like creators and scientists and
whatever what their daily routines were
and a lot of them were raging alcoholics
and on amphetamines and all kinds of
other stuff
but the ones who uh were more healthy a
daily habit a daily habit like walking
was a really big part of their routine
um visualization is a big one especially
for performers like a comedian or
something they'll often visualize the
same kind of result or professional
athletes
before they step out on the stage or
step out on the court if you want more
inspiration morning videos they're not
on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it
it's right there next to me go click it
there continue to believe
and i'll see you there